Film Courage: So let's pretend this is the moment that
you've just finished writing ALL I WANT
you just finish the script and now it's
time for you to begin marketing and and
pitch me? Who are you calling and how
are you setting up these meetings this
is before the movies made mm-hmm
you know I think this is your script.
West Liang, actor, writer, director: right right I think I think this film
taps into a certain audience who's
really interested in kind of almost
foreign cinema you know the the ideas
that happen in this movie are almost I
mean I mean you know I think I think I
think the the the lines of fracture you
know in the relationships you know and
the lives of people in the story are are
are kind of micro fractures you know but
those micro fractures you know have a
big effect on on the world of these
people and so I think I think I would
probably be interested in talking to
someone who's interested in foreign
cinema interested in in kind of indie
filmmaking the kind that doesn't you
know depend on you know these kinds of
you know garden-variety kind of plot
points about you know there is a car
crash here and there is a gun shot here
you know which all have very important
value in in different kinds of films but
I think in this film it's really nuanced
you know I think I think there's a lot
of subtext there's a lot of nuance so I
would be you know talking to people who
are who are interested in those kinds of
films so do you ever do cold calling
because you you strike me as the type
that you're not intimidated
you're not like a blustering like
salesperson but you you just opened
you kind of perceive the world that way
too so you're not really intimidated I'm
putting on a really really good thing
okay I don't know I'm just going back to
the scales I hate to bring it back to
that but yeah yeah it seems like you you
don't you're not too shy but you're not
too much of like this hardcore salesman
so if you were going to pitch it how
would you approach you know it's hard
because the the the kind of the the DNA
of this movie was not that the DNA of
this movie was very much we hadn't we
had a cast kind of in mind we had a
location in mind and and it was really
kind of writing for the resources that
we had you know and trying to make that
story as compelling as as kind of
thematically interesting as possible you
know but to answer your question I think
you know I think we would have to we
would have to what was the question
again
oh well look this role play so let's
suppose you meet with me and you don't
really know me that well but you're
gonna pitch me this idea how are you
gonna pitch me to read this screenplay
you know I I don't know where you're
meeting me right I think I think I would
I again I think I would you know really
really talk about I think I would really
you know ask him the question what are
people dealing with every day that we
don't talk about you know what and what
and what are people not what are the
secrets that people are not sharing that
impact the decisions that they make
let's make a film about
though secrets let's make a film about
those ideas that people have that they
don't share let's make a film about
those emotions that people experience
all throughout the day
that they're too afraid to kind of
explore you know this movie is not
necessarily in a traditional sense a
plot driven movie although you know the
plot is certainly kind of a driving
force just as the character is but this
story is really kind of driven by all
these different characters experiencing
something similar for whatever reason
you know and I think and I think if if
you as a producer is interested in kind
of exploring that theme you know I think
you would be interested you know because
I think honestly you know I'm not sure
that this film would be done by the
studio's unless it were attached to a
bunch of famous faces I'm thinking of
crash Wednesday so crash was great
because you saw these people that you
had a stereotype so right vision of what
they must be like and then when you
uncovered stuff behind the scene right
you saw that you know once their mask
was off absolutely they were just
fragile and and going through all sorts
of thing right and it explained their
behavior right right yeah so and I think
I think I Nathan crash is an amazing you
know story obviously was you know very
critically acclaimed and but I'm not
sure the crash would maybe get the kind
of you know attraction that it had
without you know a famous cast you know
I think that's the really frustrating
thing about the landscape of filmmaking
today is that how many stories are not
being explored how many storytellers out
there are not able to really kind of
bring interesting ideas to fruition
because the market says well we don't
have we're not interested in that
there's
audience for that there's an audience
for that I mean you know I mean the fast
and furious kind of like franchises
taking over the box office and and and
movies like that have have a lot of
entertainment value but I think it might
also scare away investors from you know
more personal movies like all I want you
know movies that are some ways foreign
in in in in tone and texture do you
think when we go to the movies we want
to know this is so-and-so actress this
is so-and-so actor I know what they're
gonna deliver me you know I I know
they're gonna have their mail right
scene and I'm gonna love it I have it
every movie I'm you know I'm not great
I'm not great at kind of understanding
how to market a film the way a lot of
kind of genius marketers are you know
like in terms of let's hit the four
quadrants and let's really kind of tap
into that kind of audience and those are
the things that I understand in an
intellectual way but that's that's not
how I kind of think about stories
emotionally so you know recently I mean
like I mean a great movie that happened
during the Oscar campaign was the lion
you know absolutely loved it
that movie was amazing and I think part
of the reason why I really enjoyed you
know Nicole Kidman's performance as an
example was that she was surrounded by
number one really amazing actors and
performers but also they were not
quote-unquote famous right and so you
naturally believed her context you
believed that she was in a world of
quote unquote real people you know and I
think that movie worked in so many ways
but I think I've had so many people say
oh I love Nicole's you know performance
in that and I said I love that too and I
think one of the reasons aside from a
masterful filmmaking is that you never
had to as an audience jump over that
kind of
obstacle of she's famous and I don't
believe that she's you know struggling I
don't believe that she's broke I don't
believe that she's XY and Z you know
she's surrounded by people who are very
kind of you know not famous and and and
and not movie stars so for me as an
audience I I gravitate towards movies
like that and so does Melissa you know
Melissa and I that's one of the things
that we kind of you know really
connected to was was but we're both fans
of kind of those kinds of films so I
think you know I'm not sure that I'm the
best person to ask about that because
there are people who say like now films
with no famous people don't get made I
don't know
you